hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
Greg and I am John I have moved to a new
apartment welcome to the new set
there is no couch couldn't fit through
the hallways damaged my wall a little
bit trying but today we're gonna catch
up on some videos fortunately now that
everything is finally celebrated to fill
me with others days and days ahead of me
I'm unpacking Kong Skull Island huh a
clip out scholars - we're gonna make two
separate videos why cuz we're youtubers
so we'll watch this clip right here
called monsters exist I believe this is
a talking clip oh boy we're
characterizing Ilia right I think Sam
Jackson and John Goodman oh never mind
cuz I believe in the trailer who's
Goodman who says that I just can't guess
marketing everything I don't know
monsters exist Wow today I was a
crackpot
but today you dropped those charges to
flush something out who are you ancient
species on this earth long before
mankind and if we keep our heads buried
in the sand they will take it back
my agency is known as monarch we
specialize in the hunt for massive
unidentified terrestrial organisms that
thing without you I'm sorry for your
Mentos I truly am get us home with proof
so we can send the cavalry
jeepers not about you but that click
plate a little weird it feels a little
bit like they cut up the scene yeah
because the first like 30 seconds I'd
say like probably saw first 30 seconds
of this 45 second clip right when he
goes monsters exist I was like a little
sudden to go there I mean I don't know
what their prior dialogue is before this
moment but one of the music and the tone
of the silence just didn't seem to quite
mesh it at that time yeah with that flow
it almost seems like they would have
been it like the dialogue still makes
sense but they it sounds like something
out of a more frantic argument if it's
gonna just flow from that idea into the
next he's gonna cut him off with
monsters exists and then the way was
cutting back and forth that felt like I
was watching two very different takes
the idea with an editing with a scene is
it's supposed to look like this is all
one scene were watching play yeah yeah
but it looked like they had a different
take of Sam Jackson reacting and
responding differently and then they use
a separate shot with John Koopman and
they sliced these two different clips
together they didn't seem like they were
quite truly playing off of each other so
looked a little strange but it also kind
of felt like they took the whole scene
and they they kind of sliced it up a
little bit to give us this clip because
I believe when you release a clip you
got to show us just the clip you don't
you shouldn't cut it up yes I mean it
might play better in the context of the
whole thing yeah I wonder I mean like
again I'm still kind of wondering which
kind of movie this is gonna turn out to
be I like stuff about this clip like I
like the the tone of the music and sort
of the thing it feels like they're going
before it feels like they're going for a
more really a monster movie yeah kind of
a bigger hide in personnel no monster
movie like that you got like this sort
of percussion yes now it feels very Jon
rough yeah and so I like some of the
tone of it and I think they're both
intense and I like them both but yeah
there's just something that's a little
not quite together yeah but I think I
feel
a dollop you know like it's a few lines
if anything yes I mean I'm not basing
anything I'm the experience of the movie
off of that I'm saying the clip itself
seemed a little cut up with yeah well
yeah John Goodman I really look forward
to John Goodman and anything he does
especially coming off of like a crazy
character in 10 Cloverfield Lane yeah
it's like I'm hoping John Goodman
becomes the next crazy actor who yeah
crazy tense guy who knows the secret
yeah you mean thing out the haired guy
who wasn't actually crazy but it's still
pretty crazy yeah exactly
and Sam Jackson playing more of you know
the deep blue sea Sam Jackson I got
questions and I want some answers I mean
this felt like a just from his point of
view that felt like it seen at it later
so like that's like alright you're gonna
fill me in on this right now because you
brought me here you didn't give me a
little story well yeah I like it when
Sam Jackson's in that position because
usually Sam Jackson gets the information
that he needs what I enjoyed about
seeing this was outside of King Kong and
wanting to see that near Kong skyline
you're not thinking I can't wait to see
Sam Jackson John Goodman in the same
scene I know I am but now but it was
kind of cool being like this Sam Jackson
and John Goodman in the same you see
it's pretty cool I'm excited to see what
they do together oh my go
this I guess this achieved the best
possible and for me in the sense that at
least for this moment I'm excited about
the cast so that's it huh we're just
some kind of Skull Island draft number
two on that Jo subscribe to the rail
rejects John's reasons to Jerry on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager a blue mouse in the real rejects
let's move on to clip number two let's
move on to clip number two